كلاريسا ، لقد وصلت للتو إلى مكان الحادث أو
بالقرب من مكان إصابة إحدى هذه
الهجمات الصاروخية بإشاراتك
القادمة والخارجة لدينا الآن ، من
فضلك أخبرنا بما تراه وما
تتعلمه جيدًا حتى جون  سأحاول ألا
أتحرك كثيرًا لأنك عندما تتحرك
كثيرًا في المواقف التي تكون فيها الإشارة
سيئة ، فإنها تخلق تشويشًا ،
لكنني أقف هنا في الأساس في موقع
إصابة أحد تلك الصواريخ ، فهذه هي
الحفرة التي تسبب فيها الضرر  بسبب
تأثير تلك الضربة ، يمكنك أن ترى أنها
ليست قدرًا هائلاً من الضرر ولكن
الأرض ناعمة جدًا ، ويمكنك أيضًا أن ترى
أنها تمطر بشدة وهناك
الكثير من الشظايا هنا على الأرض من
هذا التأثير ولكن السؤال هو
بالضبط ما  هل كان الإيرانيون يستهدفون هنا
مسؤولي الأمن المحليين الذين يخبروننا
أنه ببساطة لا يوجد شيء هنا يوجد
مخيم للاجئين على بعد ميل واحد في
هذا الاتجاه ولكن لا يوجد وجود أمريكي لا
وجود عسكري أمريكي خاصة
ربما كان هذا بالنسبة للإيرانيين  لا يتعلق الأمر
بإظهار القوة والدقة ، لكن جون
يتعلق بإظهار مدى وصول هذا الصاروخ
سوف يقطع مئات الأميال ،
فهذه واحدة من أبعد النقاط التي
تصل إليها تلك الصواريخ من الواضح أنه
ليس هناك الكثير من الراحة للأشخاص الذين يعيشون
في هذه المنطقة التي ذهبنا إليها  رؤية راعٍ في
مكان قريب من المنزل جاء جزء من السقف
في نوافذه أيضًا ،
لكن الناس هنا يميلون إلى قبول أن الحرب
أصبحت جزءًا من الحياة في العراق
تحدث جون أليسون عن مدى
روعة وقوف كلاريسا حرفيًا
في فوهة البركان  من المكان الذي أصاب فيه أحد
هذه الصواريخ ، كان
مكانًا للمعيشة ، هذا هو المكان الذي تنام فيه القوات
على الأقل في واحدة من المناطق ،
ولم يتبق شيء تقريبًا يمكن
إنقاذه ، قيل لنا إن الحفرة
نفسها قد تأثرت هنا وكانت واحدة
من 10  التأثيرات التي حدثت هنا ،
إنه حقًا غير عادي كيف تمكن أي شخص
من
عدم وقوع إصابات عندما
تنظر إلى الدمار ثم تسمع
كل القصص عن
ما نتعلمه الآن هو
أنه كان هناك تحذير متقدم إلى
درجة معينة كانوا يعلمون أن شيئًا
ما سيحدث ، لكنهم لم يعرفوا
ماذا حدث ، وحوالي الساعة 11:00 مساءً.  في الليل ،
ذهب أولئك الذين كانوا قادرين على الذهاب إلى المخابئ
إلى المخابئ ، لكن كان لا يزال هناك
جنود خارج المواقع التي
اضطروا للبقاء فيها بسبب الوضع الأمني ، لذ
ك بدأ الناس في
لاحتماء في حوالي الساعة 11:00 مس
ءً.  ثم في الساعة 1:30 ، حيث
حدث التأثير الأول ، يقول الكثير من أولئك الذين نتحدث
معهم أنه لم يكن مثل أي شيء قد تخيلوه
من قبل بالطبع من ناحية أخرى ، بدأ التدريب
ولكن في نهاية  اليوم ،
هذه تجربة
مرعبة وضع مرعب ، وهذا هو
المقدم ستايسي كولمان
الذي تحدثنا فيه طوال اليوم ، وأعني أنك كنت
تخبرنا بما كانت تلك الليلة ، مثل
كيف تبدأ حتى في وصفها
، من الصعب جدًا وصفها.  سوف
أخبرك أنه كان مخيفًا للغاية أن بعضًا من
فريقي وأنا محاصرون
وأحد تلك المخابئ وعندما
بدأت الموجة الأولى هنا
يمكنك الشعور بالصدمة وحتى
داخل المخبأ كان الضغط قويًا
لدرجة أننا شاهدنا أبواب القبو الخاصة بنا  انغمس في
الداخل نحو المخبأ
ثم الهرب مرة أخرى ، حيث كانت حوالي سبعة من
التأثيرات على مقربة شديدة من
المكان الذي جئنا فيه ، وكما قلت ،
يمكنك أن تشعر بكل واحدة من
موجات الصدمة الأخيرة  لقد كان
مخيفًا للغاية ومحظوظًا جدًا أو كان
التدريب هو الاحتياطات التي تم اتخاذها
لعدم وقوع إصابات في الولايات المتحدة ، أود أن أقول إنه
كان كل ما أقول إنه مزيج
من الله يبحث عنا ، لقد كان
مزيجًا مما تعرفه  القليل
من Intel والتحذير المتقدم الذي
تلقيناه ومن ثم كان القادة الأذكياء
على الأرض يتخذون قرارات
فورية لإخراج الناس من طريق الأذى
وكيف تبدأ في وصف ما أعنيه
، ثم بالطبع ماذا
نوع من الاحتياطات الأمنية التي يتعين
عليك اتخاذها الآن نظرًا للموقف
كان هذا كما قلت إننا نعلم أن شيئًا ما
كان يحدث لكننا لم نكن نعرف
بالضبط مع اقتراب الوقت ، اعتقدنا نوعًا ما
أن لدينا مؤشرًا على ما
قد يحدث  لكننا ما زلنا غير
متأكدين ، لذلك تلقينا تحذيرًا مسبقًا من
احتمال وجود بعض الصواريخ يتبعها
توغل في القاعدة ، ولذا كان علينا إبقاء
قواتنا الأمنية في الخارج للتأكد من
أننا كنا في مأمن من ذلك ، لذلك
كان هناك عدد لا بأس به  من  على
طول المحيط وداخل المطار ،
مما يجعله آمنًا هناك على
المحيط ، مما يجعله آمنًا
أثناء وصول هذه الصواريخ ، نعم ، لقد كانوا في
الخارج خلال كل
الضربات الصاروخية الأخيرة ، يبدو أنه
كان محظوظًا جدًا ، وكذلك كما نحن
لقد قلنا بسبب هذا
التحذير المتقدم الموجود بسبب هذه
الاحتياطات التي تم اتخاذها ، هناك
شعور بأنه في حين أن هذه المرحلة من ما
يجري قد انتهت ،
لا يزال الجميع هنا في
حالة تأهب قصوى
أروى ديمون قاعدة الأسد الجوية العراقية.